what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things Marvel and MCU I'm your host
Warren Thompson and d23 is this week and
of course everybody is really really
excited to see what is in store for
Marvel studios's future there are going
to be some huge reveals this weekend at
Marvel Studios this panel and Star Wars
as well if you are a Star Wars fan be on
the lookout for that as well but we're
really excited because Marvel Studios
gets time to talk about future projects
and at San Diego Comic-Con earlier this
year Marvel shocked us all and actually
revealed a ton of new and very very
exciting projects like the release date
for The Fantastic Four and the
announcement of two new Avengers films
Avengers the Kang Dynasty and Avengers
Secret Wars along with that they showed
us footage of some upcoming projects and
revealed new projects as well like
Captain America 4 the Thunderbolts and
Daredevil born again so what exactly is
in store this Saturday at d23 well one
of the coolest things that I think we're
going to see this weekend is some new
trailers and now that it's the week of
some rumors are going around that we are
indeed going to be getting our first
looks at some of these movies and Disney
Plus shows as well as some new trailers
for projects like black panther 2
wakanda forever and of course do not
forget about the rest of phase six they
still have many projects to reveal that
we are assuming we are going to get but
first let's talk about the trailers we
are expecting to see now first thing to
distinguish we have Disney plus day
coming up September 8th and then d23
starts September 9th and Marvel
studios's panel and lucasfilms as well
is this Saturday September 10th so the
big news for us Marvel fans is going to
be coming September 8th and September
10th now yesterday Insider Daniel rpk
announced that a secret Invasion trailer
will reportedly be released at d23 but I
think since they are having Disney plus
day they probably are going to reveal
some Marvel Studio stuff that day as
well I'm assuming they're going to give
us a little bit of a tease as to what is
coming next and of course announce some
new projects as well in fact they could
reveal a lot of Disney plus trailers one
of the Disney plus days that we got we
got a trailer for Loki for the Falcon
and the Winter Soldier and for one
division we got three trailers so don't
sleep on Disney plus day we are most
likely going to get some new
announcements there and some new
trailers for upcoming projects as well
now I'm assuming the trailers that we
are going to get for the Disney Plus
shows are going to be for secret
Invasion and the echo series these are
the first projects of phase five there
are no other Disney plus Series in
between now and secret Invasion and
rumors about an Echo trailer coming soon
have been going around for a while so
Disney plus day is the perfect day for
them to show us that so Disney plus days
should be good but moving on to d23 this
is where the juicy stuff is going to
come out now of course like I mentioned
they have to reveal the rest of phase
six but let's first talk about the
trailers we can expect to see now going
back to San Diego Comic-Con when they
showed the trailer for Black Panther
wakanda forever they released that to
the public how ever they also showed the
trailer for Ant-Man and the wasp
quantumania and Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 and those were not released to the
public now these are the next three
films that we are going to get in the
MCU black panther wakanda forever
Ant-Man and the wasp quantumania and
then Guardians of the Galaxy Vol 3. now
we've already gotten the first trailer
for Black Panther wakanda forever but
the second trailer is probably due we
only have about two months until the
movie actually comes out and we know how
Marvel Studios likes to do things they
like to release a teaser a main trailer
then they might do one more trailer but
we know they love their TV spots and
short clips that they post out kind of
every other day so timeline wise we can
expect a black panther wakanda forever
official trailer pretty soon hopefully
we get that at d23 and hopefully when it
comes out it'll actually tell us sort of
the main plot of black panther wakanda
forever because we've pretty much been
kept in the dark for a pretty long time
about what black panther 2 is actually
going to be about of course we know
Namor and Atlantis are going to be the
main antagonist but I'm expecting
there's something else there that we
really don't know about now the next is
Ant-Man and the WASP quantumania now we
know that this trailer is already done
and we know that Marvel Studios had to
save some pretty big things for d23 so
they couldn't just show this trailer to
the public at sdcc because they needed
something for this event so it is very
possible that we could be getting our
first teaser for Ant-Man and the WASP
quantumania that will show us Kang the
Conqueror now this movie comes out in
about five months so this is kind of
right around the time where Marvel
Studios starts to release trailers
sometimes it's four months but sometimes
it's five months so this is a definite
possibility now Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 is less likely if they don't show
the Ant-Man 3 trailer they are
definitely not showing the Guardians of
the Galaxy vol 3 trailer because it's
before it and when they showed the
trailer or the footage at sdcc all of
the CGI and the graphics weren't fully
done so they still could be working on
this we are quite a bit away from the
release of this movie it comes out in
May of 2023 so I'm not expecting
anything for the Guardians of the Galaxy
vol 3 especially because they introduced
a high evolutionary as the main villain
during sdcc and they had the whole
entire cast there as well I'm assuming
that they're going to save most of their
time to show a trailer or two and then
talk about their new upcoming projects
and here's exactly what I mean by this I
think some of the cast for these new
shows that have already been announced
will come out like Daredevil born again
will have Charlie Cox come on stage and
maybe once he's on stage we'll finally
get some sort of a clarification on
whether or not this is a reboot a soft
reboot or if it's just picking up right
after the Netflix Daredevil series we'll
probably also get some news about blade
Agatha coven of chaos Captain America
New World Order and hopefully maybe even
some of the cast of The Thunderbolts now
this is something that is most likely
going to happen Kevin feige goes on
stage and he has some of the cast for
these upcoming movies and shows come out
but the grand finale and pretty much the
main part that everybody is waiting for
is the full reveal of Marvel's phase six
and I believe that this will indeed take
up most of the time for example if they
are going to announce Deadpool 3 which I
am fully expecting I assume Ryan
Reynolds will come out on stage and talk
a little bit this possibility is
honestly what I am most excited for for
d23 that and of course the mutants now
there's been a lot of talk about the
mutants and what we could possibly get
from them before Avengers Secret Wars
it's very clear that in the next phase
after phase six phase seven the mutants
are going to be a big part of the MCU
the only question is are they going to
come in before Secret Wars there's a lot
of different reports out there some say
that some of the fox X-Men characters
are going to be the X-Men involved in
secret Wars which would make sense since
we are going to be talking about
variants and other universes the fox
universe is Another Universe it's all
connected of course but keep in mind
Marvel Studios has begun to introduce
the mutants in Miss Marvel so I am
hopeful that we will get some sort of an
announcement about the mute tents at d23
don't leave us hanging Kevin feige
please then of course there are other
projects that have been confirmed that
haven't been officially announced yet
like Nova I'm assuming that Nova is one
of these slots in phase six so hopefully
they announced the movie and they
announced the actor who is going to be
playing Nova and speaking of announcing
actors who are going to be playing parts
of course we hope that we get the full
cast for The Fantastic Four based off of
everything that we've heard so far it
really does seem like Marvel Studios has
either narrowed it down to a couple of
people for who they want to play each
role of the Fantastic Four or they've
already completely cast The Fantastic
Four I personally think that they've
already cast them because Kevin feige
has been working on this and has been
thinking about this project for a very
long time this is his baby it's super
important to him and if he has already
chosen the cast d23 would be the perfect
opportunity to announce the cast the
announcement of the cast of The
Fantastic Four or the announcement of a
mutant movie that's going to be be the
big finale I believe but of course let's
not forget that there are many projects
that haven't been announced for phase
six and there could be some out there
that we have no idea about that could
blow our minds we know Marvel Studios
had to save some big things for d23 they
couldn't reveal it all at sdcc so I'm
assuming we're in store for something
pretty great we didn't expect much from
sdcc but we got blown away so I'm hoping
it's the same for d23 Marvel Studios
blows us away but hey let me know your
thoughts about this in the comments down
below and don't forget to subscribe so
you can stay up to date on everything
happening this week and this weekend at
d23 please don't forget to like the
video and for live updates of course you
can follow me on Instagram and Twitter
and as always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof
foreign